welcome to this video part 9 of the
World Championship pretty serious pre
World Championship Series I'm presenting
memorable games by the two players it's
time again to present the game of the
World Champion vishy anand and we go go
back to nineteen ninety-two ready quite
a long while ago and that's a game again
against yvonne chaka had another um i
had some other eventual games before in
this series but here's one again and
very very nice game that deeply
impressed me at the time it still does
but um let's see what what happens to
put it in a bit of contacts in 1992 both
players 23 years old long time ago and
they both were considered to be sort of
the crown princess of chess one of those
players that you would expect to do to
have matches against spiral in the
future was the world champion at the
time crumley get didn't had made his
breakthrough performance performance he
only did that this a couple of months
later in the 1992 loop yet so if I shall
gain down and really were the top
candidates forum for being successes of
kasparov's so on this game was played in
a match in fact in linares it's was a
friendly match just exhibition match and
the first game we're going to look at
remember Sicilian and in fact the
classical Sicilian allowing the Rosa
good Bishop g5 the sermon was alive that
aren't played for a while he has a
banded it by now
it seems that black is under some
pressure in this opening but um nothing
that really should determine an amateur
player from playing it but on a
professional level I think black has has
slight issues okay e 60 very normal 22 a
6 or cash loans at age six yeah this at
the time was rather popular line let
them provokes the bishop to go back and
now takes on deform place b5 it's still
a fairly typical position for the
Sicilian um and you think it this is
still played nowadays once in a while
okay um f3 this is tube support in for
Queen a5 having a look at this spot so
white needs to do something to to care
about this so I played a 3 now the black
would do be formed there's a knight a
tube using the pin so before it's not
good you played b5 Bishop b3 and Bishop
e6 nothing special happening really King
be one yeah often a necessary move to
get the King out of harm's way of the
CFR trip to e7 and now I played the G
form yeah there are many other moves it
could also think about each form trying
to advance on the kingside like has not
cancelled yet this is important so
you're not going to meet him quickly
with the likes of g4
here black has a choice he can play
rugby ate what she did what what he did
I could also play before it's now a
possible move yeah let's check this
briefly of wight now retreat black can
play the interesting move d5 and yeah
it's a position like that Black has
played d 5 which is always an important
thing to go for in the Sicilian rather
unclear this position however Allen
played rugby aid which is not a bad move
him a run shall come went for 95 jokes
pretty innocuous but in fact the city
introduces now the most remarkable face
of this game a lot took and now in one
shot them actually committed a mistake
and it's very hard to to appreciate that
beforehand that the next move is a
mistake um in fact it seems that the
best move is just recapturing on d2 and
it's probably about equal however he
took on f6 and now this is this is the
first the first important point here as
island now clade G takes f6 and this is
a very remarkable move why would you
weaken your pawn structure it seems it's
a double pole and it seems to kill the
bishop the alternative was Bishop takes
of course and after white takes on d 2
at same like this um it's maybe about
equal it's nothing special really there
should be seven Mary or maybe King Kelso
think codes can also play King e7 it's
probably about equal but G take seven is
played
rook takes and now GTX F in connection
with this move is remarkably strong I
now played h5 it looks completely crazy
you first kill your bishop then you play
age 5 but what's what's the idea but
it's it's very concrete like it's
attacking this pawn and this of course
force after GTX rook takes h5 like it's
attacking this pawn what should why do
if he M cabers g4 let's say with Bishop
e2 then black takes on g4 and then
suddenly there's rook h3 attacking the
bishop and after something like
submission move may be here like we'll
go here and rook h8 and in immediately
and suddenly gets pressure against the
h-bomb so this should be two is not
really helping you cannot play h3 of
course this just gives away the bond
immediately and so some what should you
play you could you could take but after
Luke takes there's still this idea with
pressure against the edge pawn and
giving up the g4 porn also means that
there was a doubled pawns and this is a
nominally week porn and the double porn
this not a problem at all because black
can easily play a five or after some
prep d5 so you don't want to really take
on MH 5 let's say just for instance
something like this up g one like it
drums back and then goes f5 and doesn't
have any problems faq team seems to be
more comfortable here in once your plate
work g1 and this looks like the best
defense because after this you just you
just keep the pole and black cannot
enter on age three and
further increase the pressure and now
this this is the next move I i know IM
sooo remember that it really shocked me
that that this could be could be good in
fact this is the type of move that I can
easily imagine myself doing if I'd ever
do a live live comment sir for blitz
game this is the type of that you
instantly and this my instant reaction
would be okay this is this is just bad
but in fact it isn't it's one of those
moves that I immensely strong but only
am after you looked at it a bit you you
appreciate why it is a strong move yeah
what did black plane here are not played
to the remarkable move Bishop c4 and
this is just a extremely strong and
completely counterintuitive because this
is your nominally good bishop why would
you go to c4 to exchange it against the
f1 bishop yeah why does why this is
strong I mean blacks alternative would
be just to play let's say look dear King
me seven and then white gets to play age
three and just cements the King side he
might even go Bishop g2 just to protect
everything and stay put and then it's
very difficult from black to make any
sort of progress this is the strength of
this move Bishop c4 it exchanges the at
first it looks like the bed bishop but
it just allows black to make immense
progress this is an exchange that allows
black to enter on h3 let's let's see
right now play be three we also could
have taken but this is not really
helping bc3 is an immediate threat she
go nope d5 then this will be 5 also
there's still this this this week pawn
so I'm black as an excellent shape he
therefore platos he played me three some
black exchange
and now okay three so you exchange this
Bishop only six y SE for to allow the
look to enter on a tree so this is just
just great plain exchanging this at
first strong bishop for this week bishop
but you get concrete benefits from that
as you are able to attack the white
pawns because this is the interesting
point those pawns are much weaker than
black pawns this is one of those cases
where this famous saying applies bad
bishops protect good pawns this Bishop
is at first looking like a complete
[ __ ] it just sits there and protect
those pawns but it does a great job in
doing so those pawns are absolutely not
weak they cannot be attacked and black
has a very clear-cut clan at making
progress and we will see what this plan
is rupee to King d7 and yeah now white
tries to exchange off some um some
policy plays g5g kneesocks and note that
the King under the shield of the pawns
can enter the plane actively tooks
Bishop e7 very very strong retreating
and intending to use those pawns what
black is dreaming off he likes to get to
connected as pawns and we we get to
exactly that there should be one f6 them
again now but it's exactly the way you
should play in this concrete position as
black manages to play d5 note that check
like managed to exchange all white
spawns here and at the end he's got two
connected passes
this is amazing this clear-cut concept
developed right from this position we're
like managers to exchange his bad
looking pawns to at the end can get
those two strong passers it's very very
difficult to defend this white is
probably not lost but II it is closed he
played now look at five and this in fact
sets set some traps IAM like must be
careful for example if you go on King e6
the special takes in five something you
really don't want to calculate and this
is hanging King c6 is what you play
probably necessary um rugby 7s also
answered by Bishop takes and this also
makes it very difficult for for black
this is better just retreat and you you
always have those two bishops add those
two porn sorry and white cannot attack
the sir this week looking porn because
how is the bishop ever going to get them
this Bishop is much more useful than
this bishop on g3 and so we continue
look f2 and now black needs to regroup
he needs to get those pawns rolling and
the next step is to get the King to e6
which he managed it slowly improving and
now the pawns are ready to roll and
probably around here um ivanka could
have defended a bit more tenaciously but
i guess he was it was pretty shocked by
the by the concept that was was realized
in this game yeah this is very
straightforward not like slowly improved
to get
Bishop deform and now the pointer points
are marching check using this neat trick
mate on a one and the rook is saying
there's no way to to avoid material loss
now if you go this check if you go there
you lose the bishop yes how we needed to
give the exchange and that the auntie em
like breakthrough on c2 yeah here even
shook already resigned so this concept i
think is really impressive let's let's
go back to to this to this chair of the
game and review this g takes f6 look
takes and age 5s is immensely strong
you're just in danger if you if you get
this position here you're simply in
danger if you have this is black 22 just
without any thought we capture with the
bishop and think ok well let's stop much
happening he's sick so i can easily
defense it's a no big problem here which
is true but to recognize that g takes f
& h 5 is actually needing to a very good
game for black is really really strong
and this is the kind of conception where
are you yeah where you see'em
exceptional exceptional player i'm
pretty sure that it's very difficult for
for normal grandmaster to come up with
this idea like GF nh-5 nowadays maybe
because you know of this kind of games
where um where the yeah this is this
kind of exchange that you are that you
get to a position where you look passive
but at the end managed to get in all the
corn breaks connected with the smooth
when this in connection is really really
strong
until wives has really no way to prevent
to prevent at the end that those points
will get moving you could you could
actually argue feel okay the g5 wasn't
good that white probably should should
stay put but you can have a look at this
let's say what does nothing Bishop d2
going here and it's it's a problem white
defense passively and at the end we get
to something similar check and its King
6f five white cannot prevent this it's a
it's really amazing so on this is just
very very strong this G takes f6 move
and I think that he bunch of was really
shocked by equating when Allen played
this I'm just just an assumption you
cannot tell but yeah I'm still impressed
also Bishop c4 it can really happen that
you don't consider this move because why
would you exchange your at first it
looks like your best piece I mean the
bishop only seven doesn't look
particularly great and this looks like
your bed your best piece why would you
exchange it but it's just due to
concrete considerations it's the best
move and now this this is just very
strong alright a very interesting
strategical concept here and don't be
frustrated if you think well this is
nice but I would never ever come up with
it myself it's a it's just as it is and
I think myself I also never would have
come up with that but yeah those guys
really know how to play this game
alright thanks for watching I hope you
liked this interesting strategical idea
that Island presented in this game